reject nation I have a returning friend
here hello ELISA be freaking crazy last
time I saw her was at her wedding I gave
the best toast I'll say it was yes it
was
she didn't say best whatever we're
moving on Dan her hubby is in the other
room right now John is keeping him
company while we filmed this we met on
the real rejects isn't that a great
story today has worked out great because
we're doing a topper war two requests
from a mutual friend TJ trakis he said I
have a react ception request it's one of
your own videos back from the Ryan days
that I'm choosing it because it was the
very first time we ever gave me a
shout-out ever I'm wondering I remember
doing it but regardless I wanted to you
to be reminded that shout out how they
compare the other shoutouts you've given
me I look forward to it I pulled up the
video that he sent over and I'm like oh
it's a video do ELISA and ELISA and Dan
are traveling back home right now and
they wanted to stop by here to say hi
and I was like well I got you
we gotta check this video out I don't
remember - I don't remember the video we
reacted - yeah it happened to work out
perfectly yeah so it is 25th man we look
so different
baby us we look so different it's really
weird
oh my god alright let's watch this ELISA
this is gonna be cringe I feel it we are
going to cringe 2015 no terrible math it
was 13 I thought it was from like no no
is 350 oh man still 5 I've a long time
ago hey guys I'm Ryan Wright we're gonna
check out from top trending Channel
today Batman V Superman rap a battle yes
let's do this
I'm going to be actually checking out a
lot of Batman comics again one of them
is The Dark Knight Returns which
features band members and Superman which
is inspiring the new Batman V Superman
dawn of justice activities so this ran
that all better be awesome today I would
the quality of our videos has definitely
improved
I vaguely remember this now yeah this is
when I was on a lot of medication and a
lot of green
[Laughter]
[Music]
damn look at us I did not clean up my
lips
okay so much tear over my lips you look
you look very different like you look so
like I'm healthier now you look so much
more miserable since you got married
damn this is a good rap I remember this
when did you dye your hair two days ago
brand-new yeah I genuinely did not
remember this before but like this is
really good my gosh just our background
works but everything looks so much
better than that but I like that you
still have the right of the same like
components he also reference where I got
my nose I didn't have a nose job -
that's great so I really don't only know
this is a rap battle it arrives - I go
all about it and you know what
Superman was like this is why you're
kind of lame I love that man don't get
me wrong
but Superman I think we're both children
look at my listening face didn't earn
his powers in any way he's just from a
different way that's my bad man's better
because that's why his rhymes are better
because she [ __ ] works at you can
swear ouch
damn her connection with the camera so
guys the channel alright subscribe we
got here our graphics I mean that's just
okay what's up I used to tell you in the
other rejects that you all are awesome
except for the one thing mister are you
advertise your periscope but are never
on so true yes don't you says maybe you
said it quite sad yes my say on butthurt
about it so I think you should make up
for if I could give me a shout-out
TJ's ruckus I would love to give you a
shout-out Alyssa you are gay you wanna
say hey hey so Ryan Ryan
he's not my makes you feel so damn happy
makes you feel so damn good you should
you would and maybe you could sit down
on this wonderful dude you wanna make
most Ryan right well guess what man I
mean to your site I'm coming in the
night wanna get up here come out like a
Batman fright I'm gonna tell you
something today but I want you to see
to me the next time you see me behaving
crazily out on the streets ELISA buses
beat while we do these things in
stomping our feet and I'm getting my
sheets so wet with this and I want to
get me with this hey Wow okay well
definitely I think our quality audio
sound visually everything has improved
we were headphones from time to time now
we have changed drastically as people
I mean we've both chilled out a lot I
think oh yeah well still got a lot of
energy but clearly I was you see it was
a major bottom ear
some people miss those days some people
prefer that but I feel like I'm
generally happier now how about you how
do you feel I all looks can be deceiving
how are you good we already established
that I'm married now so that's a thing
but it's cool cuz it's like real rejects
family you know yeah it's just I'm
excited cuz I'm moving back here finally
happening people you're trying to find a
replace maybe you run around here yeah I
don't see her a lot she obviously got
breast reduction surgery yes really gone
downhill why'd you do that one thing
changing your nose but why the
breasticles ELISA I just I felt like I
needed a change I mean it's just like
really weird no I don't get it do you
have a sweater and I'm like they're
really like these are natural too they
just decided one day like hey we're
gonna be a thing now and I'm like well
that's great at least make it manageable
for me but now they're like we're gonna
make it like the most difficult you have
ever dealt with is it cause you back
pain oh yeah back pain it is finding
bras that fits me is a task that I have
to undergo it feels like like a mission
I was granted by an elder it's a big
deal for me to find a bra that bit I
guess
okay I guess when Alyssa and I are on
camera together the channel hasn't
changed pretty much exactly what I want
to talked about back but differences
though is that it's like we just talk
about whatever like there really aren't
any topics off-limits for us to talk
about with each other and the fact that
there's a camera and people watching
doesn't really change that means Alyssa
needs to move back down here we need to
get this train rolling again
TJ thanks so much man you see those
freestyle shoutouts I think they were
easier when I was you know a little bit
intoxicated
TJ thank you so much for supporting us
have you seen his daughter Skye
oh I've seen pictures teachers actually
come over to our house a few times
really yeah he's visited us here in LA
he's visited visited us here in
California but you haven't met the baby
I have not met the baby yet but I really
want to she seems adorable I've said
this to TJ several times like other than
like the rap shoutouts we're not
personal my shouts are more personal his
daughter when she is 18 has come a P
it's just
Horan uptown so many guys are just gonna
be I mean she might have some self
control that she won't I mean he's got
she's got a father for like TJ and we
all know what TJ's like and his daughter
oh she's gonna have a great internet
career I'll just say that much oh man oh
I hope in a good way I mean I guess it's
all in a good way depending on how you
like if no matter what you're creating
it doesn't matter what you're creating
if you're proud of your own work that's
good
me my goal with TJ and the sky is I want
him to make a compilation of all the
times I've mentioned sky and watch just
how progressively more vulgar
become and then give them to her on her
18th birthday along with my address
Oh
so I guess I'm part of this wedding
because that's just probably tell the
story at having cement I medical
assistant priceless let's rewind now
because there are so much weird games of
telephone going around how we met
through the Craigslist I got a cup of
the bridal party I have a youtube
channel like a guest of something so
he's put on an afro guess I did not put
on looking for hot women according to
all the women at the party to that I
said so
Alyssa what's the first person to
respond to you know willing to come over
to my random apartment and Dan I met
through a friend named Lauren
[Music]
you click and I left in a bowl after you
need privileges are both of them
individually for quite a while and
became close to both of that before they
ever met one another but getting to know
them it was pretty easy to go you know
it would be fun if I brought these two
together to do a YouTube video because
it's a scene of their personalities and
interest in video games that they would
just see a perfect fit so I invited over
to do a video this was after a couple
months of knowing that you guys Dan came
over first ELISA came over a little bit
later so I went to go pick up ELISA at
the front gate after that park and I
lived at there were these stairs and
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is she just got home to thought
work from jinkies and as she's walking
up the stairs you know like frozen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
before we start filming they're clicking
if you could feel that spark going off
we do find that video you'll see if
there's chemistry right there from the
very beginning where both of these guys
for a while that's just individual
people it is nearly impossible for me to
imagine them apart now and I love these
two somewhat if you just know that both
individually it makes so much sense why
these two are meant to be together they
have a similar sense of humor or similar
interesting game when they smile in a
similar smut
I just wish there were a little bit more
period with giving each other the
boyfriend-girlfriend nicknames other
than a boyfriend okay however after
today now you can call each other a
husband I love the two of you so much
you've helped me out from so many hard
times and going off on something there :
is these two sets on about silly things
quite right they stressed up with the
unique thing about them is sometimes you
get around people could get stressed out
there's not a single evil malicious bone
in either one of these two bodies aiyo
even if they're going through a hard
time
possibly so
[Music]
[Music]
the den Melissa Cheers
[Applause]